did you know that right now we're in the
middle of the biggest recall in US auto
history about 65 million airbags have
been deemed potentially unsafe this is
bigger than the next five largest
recalls combined it affects just about
one in every five cars in the United
States so if you own a car that was made
in the last 15 years there's a pretty
good chance your car has a bad airbag at
the center of the recall is a Japanese
company Takata they supply airbags to
major manufacturers like Honda and
Toyota and Ford and all of these guys so
the problem is some of these widely
distributed Takata airbags are
malfunctioning but it's not just that
the bags aren't inflating when cars with
these airbags get into an accident the
bag explodes they use a chemical called
ammonium nitrate as a propellant but
over time it's begun to destabilize the
casing that's holding the ammonium
nitrate breaks apart and it does so so
violently that it ends up sending metal
shards flying into drivers and
passengers ten people in the United
States have been killed by Takata
airbags and almost all of them have died
in the southern half of the country it
turns out that long exposure to heat and
humidity are what's causing the ammonium
nitrate to destabilize so what now
Takata is obviously in trouble the
Department of Justice is conducting
criminal investigation
there's also trouble for the owners of
the cars of the bad bags because while
you can go to this website and see if
your car is on the list and then bring
it into a dealership your problems are
really probably just starting since air
bags on each make and model of car are
unique replacing 65 million of them
requires a lot of parts that are in very
high demand right now and it may take
until 2019 to fix every effective car
this is leaving people with cars that
are dangerous to drive but impossible to
fix and all because of the device and
their steering wheels that was put there
to keep them safe
you